And there's 2 correct answers here.
The first one is that the size of this huge Boolean formula here
is polynomial in n, and I will show you why.
First of all, how large is each one of these formulas that we're building?
Well, there's a constant number of variables
and as I showed you before,
if you want to ensure that for a constant number of variables,
only exactly one of them
can be set to true,
then the resulting formula
is about the square of the number of variables that you have
and since we have a constant number of variables,
each formula here is about the size of the square of that constant,
so we have--
it's kind of O of c squared, and c does not depend on the size of the inputs,
so in a way, we can even write this as O of 1.
Now we have a polynomial number
of these Boolean formulas,
so we have a polynomial n times the constant;
this is again a polynomial of n,
so we're fine on this side here.
We're also fine on this side here, because the formulas again are
of constant size;
it can, of course, be a huge size,
especially if you have a system that can carry very large variables,
but nevertheless, it's a constant size,
and that's all we care about; it does not depend on the size of the input,
and we have a polynomial number of them again here.
And finally, the code also has a constant number of lines,
and so the Boolean formula resulting from that
will also have constant size,
so overall, this huge formula here
has a size that is polynomial in n.
Does this formula have only one satisfying assignment?
No, it doesn't; it has a huge number of satisfying assignments,
but each of those satisfying assginments
will ensure that exactly one of the variables here is set to true and so on,
and this gives us the third property,
which means that this satisfying assignment
defines a snapshot, because it will tell you exactly what's in this memory cell here
and so on.
It will tell you exactly where the program is at
and it will also tell you exactly
what's here in this memory.
And once we have this,
you have actually completed the most difficult step of this unit
in my mind,
and we are now ready to show that
sat is np complete.